faire ses courses de noël sur internet
une pratique désormais à disposition de
bien des parents qui font leur marché
aux jouets directement sur la toile
elisabeth est gelée vers dar connard
la lettre au père noël a fait ses
preuves pour leurs commandes marine et
valentin s'ils prennent toujours de la
même façon
je voudrais la scène des plis mobil
1 actional
12 et un vélo mais leurs parents
changent de méthode depuis deux ans pour
limiter le stress et la corvée des
courses il choisit sur catalogue et
achètent sur le nazisme et ensuite la
cuisine des tout petits les jouets sont
10% plus cher qu'en grande surface et la
livraison à domicile en 48 heures coûte
10 euros par commande mais c'est tout
confort
je commande j'irai une moitié sur sur le
net l'autre en grande surface mais pour
moi c'est avant tout un moyen pratique
et rapide
les jouets arrive très rapidement et
lorsque l'on n'est pas sept sites fait
on a quand même la chance de les
renvoyer
ici les jouets descendent du ciel
réellement par milliers deux cent
cinquante mille articles dans cet
entrepôt nous sommes près de lille chez
le numéro un de la vente de jouets par
correspondance pour honorer les seize
mille commandes journalières le père
noël a besoin de beaucoup dead en ce
moment l'effectif est multiplié par 7 2
millions de jouets vont être livrées
dans toute la france en décembre sont
aujourd'hui sur croissance de 10% à
l'année avec une très forte part de
marché sur le net nous avons aujourd'hui
20% ne commande qui arrivent par le net
par l'aspect faciliter l'ensemble de nos
clients mais globalement c'est une
percée encore timide seulement 85 % des
jouets sont achetés par correspondance
contre 44% en hyper et supermarchés
du ski